OmmeUUuuhh
Salut, le 15 novembre quand je vous ai fait une vidéo sur la douleur
je vous ai proposé de parler de la méditation.
Je vous ai demandé votre avis, vous étiez moult, moult, moult à dire Oui
donc derrière ce titre putaclic se cache une vidéo sur la méditation
Mais avant de commencer je voulais revenir sur le jeu que je vous offre pour les 200 000 abonnés
le cadeau que je vous fais, j'en ai parlé dans la vidéo de lundi
il y a eu beaucoup de questions par rapport à ça.
Alors je réponds aux questions les plus posées
en 3 points.
1er point: vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour vous inscrire
comme ça je laisse passer le week end et dimanche soir je coupe les inscriptions
et on va commencer à préparer tout pour les envois
2ème point,
beaucoup se disent, et ça m'a bien fait rire,
mais si j'envoie une enveloppe avec ma propre adresse
L'enveloppe elle revient chez moi
C'est pas faux ça
Alors ce qu'il se passe, c'est que vous allez recevoir un mail de ma part
avec une petite vidéo explicative et une adresse
A cette adresse, vous allez envoyer une enveloppe
jusque là c'est clair
et qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans cette enveloppe
il y aura une autre enveloppe que vous aurez préparé
avec votre adresse dessus et des timbres
une enveloppe format A5 que vous plierez, pourquoi pas avec votre adresse, timbrée
vous la mettez dans l'autre enveloppe, que vous m'envoyez
et si vous habitez à l'étranger peu importe où
C'est pas un souci
Il suffit juste que vous mettiez assez de timbre pour être sûr que l'enveloppe va revenir
Il y a pas un poids démentiel, c'est un poids tout à fait classique
donc vous timbrez ça comme n'importe quelle enveloppe
et 3ème point,
Pourquoi j'envoie pas un truc par mail
Parce qu'il y a quelque chose que je ne peux pas envoyer par mail déjà
et j'ai envie de faire un cadeau à la base donc c'est un vrai truc physique et
c'est pas pour envoyer un mail qui n'a pas de valeur
c'est pour que vous ayez vraiment du courrier
avec quelque chose dedans
Maintenant que tout ça est dit
Générique
*Musique du générique*
Dans cette vidéo sur la méditation
mon but c'est surtout de vous dire, rapidement, ce qu'est la méditation
et comment la pratiquer
c'est plutôt adressé aux débutants
Alors, pourquoi, quand, comment, combien
Pourquoi c'est pas compliqué, c'est pour calmer le mental
justement toute cette année sur les vidéos
je vous apprends à faire des choses avec votre tête
à être plus vigilant, à être peut être plus rapide
en tout cas j'espère
Mais au final, il y a un espèce de comme ça d'hymne au cerveau
alors que le cerveau, le mental il faut savoir aussi le calmer
c'est très important
Et le but de la méditation c'est de stopper comme ça un flux permanent d'idées
de différents jugements que l'on porte sur soi même
ou sur ce qui nous entoure
pour retrouver une vraie perception
une vraie perception dont on a même plus conscience
J'aborderai même pas le côté spirituel de la méditation
mais juste la méditation comme étant un outil
pour se recentrer un petit peu et pour, comme je le disais
Calmer le mental
Mais quand pratiquer. N'importe quand
peu importe
le matin, le midi, le soir, l'après midi
Ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
Combien de temps qui est une question qu'on me pose souvent quand on sait que je fais de la méditation
Combien de temps on médite?
Le mieux c'est comme pour tout c'est de le faire régulièrement
donc je vous recommande
de faire plutôt 10 minutes mais 10 minutes tout les jours
parce qu'en même temps 10 minutes c'est rien à trouver en terme de temps dans une journée.
On a tous 10 minutes, 10 minutes au réveil par exemple ça peut être un rituel comme ça au réveil
c'est trèèès bien
et comment?
Alors il y a plein de formes différentes de méditation
je ne vais pas vous faire les explications, là comme ça, de toutes ces formes là
Mais ce que je vais vous proposer ça se rapproche plus de la méditation en pleine conscience
c'est une méditation qui est basée sur l'instant
sur le moment présent
et sur ce que vous êtes
Tout d'abord vous trouvez un endroit calme
où vous serez pas dérangés
vous mettez tout ce qui est téléphone etc...en mode avion, vous éteignez l'ordinateur
vous débranchez la sonnette même si vous pouvez
Deuxièmement vous vous mettez dans une position  dans laquelle vous êtes à l'aise.
une des bonnes positions c'est d'être assis à 90 degrés, 90 degrés
c'est à dire un angle de 90 degrés au niveau des genoux et un angle de 90 degrés le dos appuyé contre un dossier
en tout cas ne faites pas de la méditation allongé
c'est pas quelque chose que je recommande
parce que le but n'est pas de s'endormir
Croyez moi je me suis déjà endormi plusieurs fois
Les yeux ouverts ou fermés ça n'a pas d'importance
il y en a qui pratiquent les yeux mi-clos, qui regardent un petit peu le lointain
c'est à dire qu'ils regardent ce qu'il y a devant eux sans vraiment regarder
un peu comme quand on est comme ça
Personnellement je préfère le faire les yeux fermés
mais après c'est une question de choix, à vous de voir
Je vous ai fait déjà des vidéos sur le fait de pouvoir se relaxer par la respiration, ce genre de chose
donc vous allez vous concentrer sur votre respiration
comme nous l'avons vu précédemment
et vous allez prendre conscience de tout votre corps, des orteils jusqu’à la tête.
Mais 1 par 1
c'est ça qui prends du temps.
Ça peut prendre 3, 4, 5, 6 minutes
sur votre séance complète ça parait beaucoup
mais pourtant c'est un processus nécessaire
Donc, et c'est là qu'on commence à se marrer.
pour se relaxer, d'abord, les orteils.
Il faut prendre réellement conscience de ses orteils
les ressentir, sentir le contact de l'orteil contre la chaussure, par exemple, contre la chaussette
est ce qu'il y a des points de pression, les visualiser
vraiment prendre conscience de cet endroit là du corps
et tenter de le détendre mentalement
de se sentir complètement abaissé à cet endroit là
et après vous allez remonter le pied,
vous allez faire le même travail aux chevilles
puis aux mollets, aux genoux, aux cuisses, au bassin, aux fesses,
au torse, au dos, aux épaules, au cou, aux bras, poignets, mains, doigts, tous les éléments de votre visage
jusqu'au crâne
Déjà quand vous aurez fini ça
vous vous sentirez déjà mieux
pour la deuxième partie, vous pouvez faire, ce qu'on appelle une méditation guidée
alors guidée par un livre audio par exemple, il y a des audios qui existent sur YouTube de méditation
qui vous parle en même temps et qui vous guide littéralement
mais ça peut être aussi en écoutant une musique particulière
Moi ce que je préfère sur la méditation guidée, c'est les bols tibétains
La méditation avec les bols tibétains
Le mieux ça c'est quand c'est en réel
quand quelqu'un est en train de jouer des bols en réel
mais il existe aussi des audios là dessus
et pour les audios, il y a une application que je recommande, qui est gratuite, qui s'appelle Petit BamBou
je crois qu'ils ont quelques cours gratuit en fait
c'est pas l'intégralité de l'application
mais si vous n'avez jamais pratiqué de méditation, vous pouvez commencer par ceux là
et continuer après vous tout seul
Mais ça peut vous aider de commencer par ça, par une méditation guidée
Je vous le redis quand même c'est Petit BamBou
et ce n'est pas un placement de produit
Le but de votre méditation, ensuite,
c'est de ne penser à rien, d'être dans l'instant
alors ne penser à rien ça ne se peut pas
vous pouvez focaliser un petit peu sur un objet ou sur une musique comme on l'a vu
et vous allez être parasités par d'autres pensées, ne les refusez pas
il faut juste regarder cette pensée là sans jugement
sans se dire pourquoi elle arrive
sans chercher à la comprendre, sans chercher à la résoudre si il y a une problématique
et vous allez voir qu'elle va s'estomper
au fur et à mesure
C'est un petit peu comme un nuage
et si on regardait longtemps le nuage, et bien il partirait
et au fur et à mesure il y en aura de moins en moins
et vous allez donc calmer le mental
et être pleinement conscient de l'instant présent, d'où vous êtes, de qui vous êtes
C'est ça... Le But final
Méditer c'est se détendre, c'est ne rien faire
et c'est juste être dans l'acceptation, sans jugement
Voilà, je pense que cette vidéo est assez longue comme ça
Ce sera un espèce de MasterClass, astuce, méditation, hors sujet mais pas complètement
J'espère que ça vous servira et que ça vous a plu
Si ça vous a plu comme vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce en l'air c'est important
Petite info du jour, dans 1h sur la chaîne de Youtunes
je sais pas si vous connaissez Youtunes
il y a une vidéo qui sort. Il m'a demandé quelque petites choses
Je lui ai envoyé
et il en a fait un remix
et je vais découvrir ça en même temps que vous à 18h
[Chantonnant] YOUTUNES
Si vous avez d'autres méthodes de méditation n'hésitez pas, également, à en parler dans les commentaires
et à vous répondre entre vous pour échanger vos savoirs
Ça c'est toujours intéressant
Si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous pouvez, également, vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
et le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h
ouais mon gars
Ciao !